Sylvester Stallone is pumped to be
playing John J Rambo one last time and
that excitement seems to be fueled by
some new creative energy as he's done
several times in recent months the star
took to Instagram to share new images
and backstory text for his upcoming
movie giving us a deeper insight into
the iconic character whose story he'll
be closing out with Rambo five last
blood introduced in 1982 s first blood
Rambo was never given much of a detailed
history beyond being a Green Beret who
as you know are real bad assets at the
time the fact that he was trained to
ignore pain live off the land and eat
things that would make a billy goat puke
was all the backstory that we needed but
sli's latest post the big thing the
one-man army is a fresh-faced young man
not yet molded into the ultimate killing
machine contains some surprisingly
specific details about Rambo's time in
the military it also alluded to the idea
that for him
war is more of a constant state of mind
than anything else a second photo most
likely taken on set of the movie shows
sly in character as he's either nursing
a serious headache or about to kill
somebody
perhaps Pope the saga of Rambo was one
of the more reliable action franchises
of the 80s despite the fact that first
blood was never intended to launch a
series the first flick was adapted from
a novel of the same name by David Morel
in which a mysterious traumatized
Vietnam vets is pursued by police
through the forests of the Northwest
he's being chased down for the petty
crime of vagrancy and the pursuit does
not end well for the police in the novel
Rambo ends the story by taking his own
life a fate which was almost shared by
the character in the movie in fact
Stallone had to talk first blood
director Ted coach F into cutting poor
Rambo a break altering the ending after
the original scene had been shot
although the film got mixed reviews it
cleaned up at the box office for the
sequel 1985 s Rambo First Blood Part 2
the character transitioned from put-upon
antihero to full-on
agent of death the follow up saw Rambo
returning to Vietnam on a fact-finding
mission which eventually evolved into a
one versus everyone gunfight that seemed
to involve the entire country that film
also put up numbers at the box office
rendering the name Rambo
as shorthand for badass for the rest of
the decade and beyond thinks he's Rambo
Rambo is 1988's Rambo 3 moved the action
to Afghanistan and seemingly served as
an end to the series until 2008 two
decades after Rambo 3 Stallone returned
to work both sides of the camera in the
simply titled Rambo the fourth movie saw
our hero laying low minding his own
business as a snake catcher in Thailand
before being forced into action to
protect a group of missionaries from
corrupt Burmese soldiers while the
movies reviews were mixed franchise fans
mostly found it to be a satisfactory
continuation of Rambo story and we're
also blown away by its insane level of
bloody violence now comes Rambo 5
throughout the production of the series
his final installment Stallone is popped
up on Instagram to share set photos that
help sketch out the story among those
photos is a cowboy hat sporting Rambo
looking intense and a rainstorm another
with him riding a horse an image of
Rambo and his bow and arrow and a short
series highlighting the film's co-stars
helping to fill in some more details as
the movie's official synopsis which
helps to explain the cowboy hats
according to the summary Rainbow five
will see John Rambo living and working
on a ranch in Arizona but this is no
pastoral life
John's violent past has left him feeling
deeply troubled suffering from PTSD when
a longtime family friend informs him
that her granddaughter has gone missing
in Mexico he sets off with her to locate
the young woman the journey leads him to
uncover a ring of sex traffickers and
kidnappers led by a vicious crime lord
whom he must stop at all costs as we all
know being deeply troubled and
traumatized by combats has never kept
Rambo from bringing the pain in the past
and we don't see any reason why this
final outing would be any different
while no release date has been announced
Rambo 5 is expected to hit screen
sometime in 2019 but just because it's
the end of the line for the Vietnam vet
doesn't mean it won't be fun to watch
and draw last blood it sounds like it's
very depressing but it's an effect it's
a kid's film check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single
one
[Music]